SEAN HANNITY WATCHITY,.
>> WE BEGIN OUR "HANNITY WATCH"
ON HUGE, MASSIVE POLITICAL HIP
OCINCREASE TONIGHT.
NOW, DEMOCRATS, YOU WATCH THEM
CLOSELY, PEOPLE ON THE LEFT,
THEY CLAIM TO HAVE A MONOPOLY OF
COMPASSION.
CONSERVATIVES ARE COLD HEARTED,
THEY'RE EVEN SELFISH AND GREEDY
BECAUSE THEY WANT LOW TAXES AND
LES GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
THEY SAY WE'RE MEAN SPIRITED,
WANTING  TO CURTAIL ENTIGHT EL
WANTS.
NOT TRUE.
I DON'T KNOW REPUBLICAN THAT IS
WANT TO GET RID OF SOCIAL
SECURITY OR MEDICARE.
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE CAMPAIGN
LIES.
OR IF YOU DON'T.
>> WHAT COMES IS A REAL LIFE OR
DEATH CRISIS, AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, THEY ARE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.  THE DEMOCRATS, THE
RADICAL LEFT NEW TALKING POINT
IS TO CALL WHAT IS DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION AND CHAOS, CAUSED BY
UNSECURED BOARDS, NOTHING MORE
THAN A MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
WATCH THIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST STOP
HOLDING PEOPLE HOSTAGE.
STOP MANUFACTURING A CRISIS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT JUST USED THE
BACKDROP OF THE OVAL OFFICE TO
MANUFACTURE A CRISIS.
>> FOLKS, THE PRESIDENT HAS
MANUFACTURED ONE HECK A
POLITICAL CRISIS FOR HIMSELF.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS MANUFACTURE
AID NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
YOU WILL HEAR THEM SAY, THIS IS
A MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
IT'S NOT A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
>> THE BIG SCAM OF THE WHOLE
ADDRESS WAS THAT THERE'S A
CRISIS.
THERE'S NOT A CRISIS.
>> THE NOTION THAT WE HAVE A
CRISIS THERE SECURITY CRISIS IS
ABSOLUTE NONSENSE.
>> IT REMAINS A "SEINFELD"
SHUTDOWN, ALL ABOUT NOTHING.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE IS A
REAL CRISIS?
WHEN THERE'S A REAL EMERGENCY?
DOES HE TAKE TO THE AIR WAVES?
DO WE GIVE HIM AIR WAVES?
DO WE BELIEVE HIM.
>> THERE IS NOT A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
IT'S A MANUFACTURED CRISIS FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO GET A POLITICAL
WHIM.
>> HE'S DETERMINED TO CONVINCE
YOU, THERE IS A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
EVEN THOUGH AN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL, TELLS CNN QUOTE, NO
ONE SAYING THIS IS A CRISIS
EXCEPT THEN.
>> FIRST THING OFF YOU'VE GOT TO
NOTICE, YOU NOTICE HOW YOU HATE
TRUMP DEMOCRATS, THEY SPEAK IN
ONE VOICE.
THEY HAVE ONE TALKING POINT,
NOW, TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING.
AS PROMISED, YOU WILL NOT SEE ON
ANY OTHER NETWORK AND WE'RE
GOING ON SHOW WHAT YOU REAL
VICTIMS OF A CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
TAKE A LOOK THERE.  MEN, WOMEN,
HUSBANDS, WIVES, CHILDREN,
PARENTS, THOSE ARE ALL HUMAN
BEINGS THAT OF COURSE KILLED
BECAUSE WE HAVE UNSECURE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THOSE ARE REAL NAMES.
THAT INCLUDES POLICE OFFICER
RONALD S.E.C. HE WAS GUNNED DOWN
BY THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT, JUST
AFTER CHRISTMAS AND OFFICER
SINGH, LEAVING BEHIND A WIFE AND
A 5-MONTH-OLD BABY BOY WHO WILL
NEVER KNOW HIS FATHER.
DEMOCRATS ARE YOU REALLY
PREPARED, THE MEDIA, DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, LIBERALS, ARE YOU GOING
TO LOOK AT THIS MAN'S FACE AND
TELL THEM THAT THIS DEATH SAY
MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
WHERE HAVE YOUR HEARTS GONE?
EARLIER THIS WEEK, WE INTRUDE
THE PARENTS OF THIS YOUNG MAN,
PIERCE COCORAN AND HE WAS KILLED
BY A SUSPECTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT, DRIVING  ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THE HIGHWAY WITHOUT A
LICENSE, WITHOUT INSURANCE IN
THE COUNTRY, 14 YEARS.
ARE DEMOCRATS GOING TO CALL THE
COCORANS AND TELL THEM WHAT
HAPPENED, THAT THEIR SON SAY
MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
WHAT ABOUT JOSH WILKERSON OR
DOMINIC DIRDON OR SERGEANT MEN
DOZE A OR GRANT RONEBURGER, I
CAN KEEP GOING.
DO DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT TO YOU
BELIEVE THIS IS SOME GRAND
CONSPIRACY, A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS?
NOW, WE DO HAVE ANGEL PARIS.
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
CHILDREN, THEY ARE SPEAKING OUT
TONIGHT AND THEY HAVE DONE SO
MANY TIMES  IN THE PAST AND THEY
ARE REMINDING SOME OF AMERICAN'S
POLITICIANS  AND THEIR BEST
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA THAT THIS
IS NOT A POLITICAL GAIN FOR
THEM.
THIS IS A CRISIS, A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER, REAL AMERICANS
LOSING REAL LIVES, NEEDLESSLY.
AND REAL FAMILIES SUFFERING.
IF YOU MIGHT SAY A WORD,
PERMANENT SEPARATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
M WHEN YOU HEAR CHUCK SCHUMER
AND NANCY PELOSI LAST NIGHT
SAYING THE PRESIDENT HAS
MANUFACTURED A CRISIS TO SELL
THIS WALL WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO
THE TOP DEMOCRATS.
>> IT MAY SEEM MANUFACTURED TO
THEM M BECAUSE THEY'RE SITTING
BEHIND WALLS BUT FOR THOSE OF US
OUT IN REGULAR AMERICA WE ARE
VICTIMS.
WE ARE BROTHER-IN-LAW TO THE
VICTIMIZATION OF ILLEGAL AIL I
DIDN'T KNOWS  AND CRIME.
>> I'M JUST WONDERING, HOW MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE HAD THEIR
SONS, DAUGHTERS, WIVES OR
HUSBANDS' LIVES SNUFFED OUT.
I'M WONDERING IF NANCY PELOSI'S
CHILDREN OR GRANDCHILDREN ARE
ASSAULTED THE WAY MY SON WAS
ASSASSINATED, IF SHE WOULD SPEAK
THE SAME WAY.
>> Tucker: LAST TIME I WAS WITH
DONALD GOVERNOR PERRY, SAT IN A
SECURITY BRIEFING.
642,000 CRIMES COMMITTED AGAINST
TEXANS ALONE IN A 7 YEAR PERIOD,
IN JUST THE PAST TWO YEARS
ALONE.
4,000 CRIMINAL ALIENS HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED FOR HOMICIDE.
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES.
CRIMINAL IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR TENSE OF
THOUSANDS OF MURDERS.
NOW, TO THESE FAMILIES, OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS, THAT CRISIS IS
ALWAYS PRESENT.
THEIR LIVES HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED, FOREVER ALTERED,
THEIR LOVED ONCE MURDERED.  AND
HATE TRUMP DEMOCRATS.
HATE TRUMP TALKING POINT MEDIA
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE TO SUGGEST THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
REALLY?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN ALL TOO
COMMON OCCURRENCE.
IT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
LAW ABIDING MEN AND WEANLINGS
KILLED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THAT
DON'T RESPECT OUR LAWS, OUR
SOVEREIGNTY, OUR BORDERS.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE HERE AT A. IF
WE SECURED THE BORDERS, LIVES
ARE GOING TO BE SAVED.
PEOPLE WILL BE PROTECTED.
IT WON'T BE PERMANENT SEPARATION
AS IN THE CASE WE'RE TELLING YOU
ABOUT.
MANY OF THESE CASES, THOSE
RESPONSIBLE, EVEN HAD LONG,
CRIMINAL TRACK RECORDS.
SOME HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
DEPORTED, ALL GAINING ACCESS,
BECAUSE OUR SOUTHERN BOARD SORRY
WIDE OPEN AND SADLY, THIS IS
ONLY ONE ASPECT OF THE CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS, 30,000
CRIMINAL ALIENS ARRESTED FOR SEX
CRIMES, OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
WERE VIOLENT ASSAULTS.
IN 2018, 800 GANG MEMBERS
APPREHENDED AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THAT'S A 50% INCREASE OVER THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
YES, LAST YEAR, WE ALSO SAW
122 PERCENT INCREASE IN FENTANYL
BEING SMUGGLED ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, THAT'S THE DRUG
KILLING AMERICANS EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN THIS C. THE DEADLY
SUBSTANCE, OFTEN MIXED  WITH
HEROIN.
90% OF THAT, SMUGGLED ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BOARDER AND KEEP IN
MIND, EVERY 7 DAYS, 300
AMERICANS WILL DIE FROM A HEROIN
OVER DOSE.
THAT DEATH TOLL IS EQUAL TO THE
NUMBER OF AMERICAN TROOPS KILLED
EVERY WEEK IN VIETNAM, DURING
1968.
THAT WAS THE DEADLIEST YEAR THAT
HAVE WAR.
SO IS THAT A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS?
LAST YEAR, 17,000 INDIVIDUALS
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
APPREHENDED 60,000 INADMISSIBLE.
OR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TURNED
AWAY FROM OUR BORDERS.
20,000 CHILDREN, SMUGGLED OR
TRAFFIC INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS NOT A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS OR A TALKING POINT.
THOSE CHILDREN MATTER, THOSE
WOMEN MATER.
AND 98% THAT WANT A BETTER LIFE
FOR THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILY,
CHILDREN, GRANDCHILDREN, ONE OUT
OF EVERY THREE MIGRANT WOMEN,
WHO MAKE THAT DANGEROUS TRIP,
TRY TO MAKE IT INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY'RE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND 7
IN 10 MIGRANTS REPORTED BEING
VICTIM DURING THAT TREK.
AND THEY REQUIRE EMERGENCY AND
MEDICAL CARE AFTER THEY ARRIVE.
AND THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, HAVE DIED TRYING TO
CROSS UNFAMILIAR DESERTS, IN
UNSECURED REGIONS.
AND DON'T FORGET THE RISKS THAT
ARE POSED  TO OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
UNVETTED, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD, USE OUR
UNSECURED SOUTHERN BORDER, IN
ORDER TO GAIN ACCESS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SARA CARTER RECENTLY TOOK A TRIP
TO THE BORDER, ACTUALLY
INTERVIEWED TWO INDIVIDUALS.
>> BANGLADESH.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN WALKING?
>> THREE MONTHS.
>> 3 MONTHS.
PLEASE PUT YOUR HANDS DOWN.
DON'T WORRY.
I'M A JOURNALIST.
THREE MONTH?
>> YEAH.
>> FROM BANGLADESH THROUGH
MEXICO.
>> YEAH.
>> TO THE UNITED STATES.
YEAH.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT
RIGHT NOW.
>> NO.
>> WHO BROUGHT YOU HERE?
WHO HELPED YOU?
>> DUBAI, BRAZIL, AND THEN
THROUGH CENTRAL AMERICA.
AND THEN UP HERE TO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> AND YOU HAVE THE MEETING
DEMOCRATS TELLING YOU, THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE FROM
SARA'S TRIP TO THE BORDER COMING
UP.
YOU'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO WANT
TO SEE WHAT SHE HAS DELIVERED.
ALSO LAST NIGHT, IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE ISSUES,
THE PRESIDENT DELIVERED A
POWERFUL ADDRESS, UNVEILED A
PLAN TO FIX THIS CRISIS, BUT THE
LEFT, THEIR FRIENDS, THEIR
WILLING ACCOMPLICES AND THEIR
MEDIA DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE.
SETH MEYERS, LATE NIGHT, JOKE
BIRTHDAY DEVASTATION AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IS THE OVAL OFFICE S.V.U. AND
U.S. CONGRESSWOMAN, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ EVEN CALLING FOR
I.C.E. TO BE ABOLISHED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WOMEN AND CHILDREN ON THAT
BORDER THAT ARE TRYING TO SEEK
REFUGE AND OPPORTUNITY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, WITH
NOTHING BUT THE SHIRT OFF THEIR
BACKS.
THEY'RE ACTING MORE AMERICAN
THAN ANY PERSON WHO SEEKS TO
KEEP THEM OUT.
A CHILD DIED IN I.C.E. CUSTODY,
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT BE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY TO AN
AGENCY THAT HAS SYSTEMATICALLY
VIOLATED HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE REALLY
DEFENDING WHY WE ARE FUNDING
SUCH AN AGENCY AT ALL.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS DEATH.
RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
THE VIOLATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
THESE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE
BEING HELD IN WHAT ARE CALLED
LLELERAS FREEZING BOXES, THAT NO
PERSON SHOULD BE MAINTAINED IN.
THIS IS SYSTEMATIC.
IT IS WRONG AND IT IS
ANTI-AMERICAN.
>> WOW.
THAT'S NBC REPORTING.
OCASIO CORTEZ.
NOT THE ONLY DEMOCRAT LIVING IN
THIS FANTASY WORLD.
IN A BIZARRE SPEECH, WORTHY OF
A "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" OPEN
SKIT.
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCKY SCHUMER,
LITERALLY, THEY ARE SCOWLING AS
THEY OFFERED ZERO SOLUTION TO
THE CRISIS AND THEY START
PUSHING THE MANUFACTURED CRISIS
LINE:  IS THIS THE LIBERAL
COMPASSION THAT THEY LECTURE US
ABOUT ALL THE TIME?
DO THEY NOT CARE ABOUT HUMAN
BEINGS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER?
LONG TIME STRATEGIST, HE MADE A
JOKE ABOUT SCHUMER'S FORCE.
DEMOCRATIC REBUTTAL.
DEAD ON ACCURATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY WANTED TO
DO IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
DONE IT AND I GUARANTEE YOU, AT
THE STAFF MEETING TOMORROW
MORNING, SOMEBODY IS GOING TO
GET, YOU KNOW, CHEWED OUT PRETTY
GOOD.
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
THEY COULD GIVE A GETTIESBERG
ADDRESS AND DIDN'T MATTER.
I'VE BEEN MORE EXCITED ABOUT
COLONOSCOPIES THAN HIS SPEECH
TONIGHT.
>> FUN AND HE TRUE AND ACCURATE,
BUT NOT REALLY A LAUGHING MATTER
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE MY
23RD YEAR HERE AT FOX.
I HAVE INTRUDE WAY TOO MANY
ANGEL MOMS, DADS, BROTHERS  AND
SISTERS OVER THE YEARS, PEOPLE
THAT LOST CHILDREN, ARE PAYING A
PAIN THAT NEVER MOST RECOVER
FROM.
AND THIS IS A PAIN IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT IS LOOKING  TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM, OPENING THE DOOR TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
URGES LAWMAKERS FROM BOTH
SYSTEMED OF BOTH PARTIES TO COME
AND NORTH, BUT DURING TODAY'S
MEETING, DEMOCRATS AGAIN THEY'RE
NOT INTERESTED AT ALL.
FOR THEM, POLITIC OFFENSE TRUMPS
ALL.
I WANT TO TURN FLOOR OVER, THE
PRESIDENT SAID TO, SPEAKER
PELOSI.
SHE BEGAN TO ARGUE, WHETHER WE
HAVE A CRISIS OR WHETHER FACTS
ARE TRUE.
TURNED TO SCHUMER AGAIN, WHO
SAID, WE JUST HAVE TO OPT
GOVERNMENT UP.
THE PRESIDENT TURNED TO THE
SPEAKER.
AND POLITELY ASKED HER, OKAY,
NANCY, IF WE OPT GOVERNMENT UP,
IN 30 DAYS, COULD WE HAVE BORDER
SECURITY?
SHE RAISED HER HAND AND SAID NO,
NOT ALL THOSE IN FAVOR.
THE PRESIDENT CALMLY SAID, I
GUESS YOU'RE STILL NOT WANTING
TO DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM THAT'S WHY HE
CONTINUES TO BRING TO THEM.
THAT'S WHY HE'S PUT OFFER ON THE
TABLE NOT ONCE HAVE THE
DEMOCRATS OFFERED GOING BACK.
AND WAY THEY DISPLAYED THE
BEHAVIOR IS EMBARRASSING  TO ME.
>> IN 2006.
DEMOCRATS HAD A VERY DIFFERENT
PERCEPTION AND DIFFERENT IDEAS,
AND THEY AND REPUBLICANS CAME
TOGETHER TO FUND A PARTIAL
BORDER WALL.
THEY SUPPORTED THEN, THE SECURE
FENCE ACT, ALLOWED OVER
$50 BILLION OVER THE NEXT TWO
DECADES  TO CONSTRUCT AND
MAINTAIN HUNDREDS OF MILES OF
NEW BARRIERS.
64 DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE VOTED
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL AND THE
SENATE, BOTH PARTIES, INCLUDING
CHUCKY SCHUMER AND SENATOR
HILARY CLINTON AND BOXER AND
FEINSTEIN AND BARACK OBAMA VOTE
TO FUND THE WALL.
CAMPUS REFORM, ASKED COLLEGE
STUDENTS  TO REACT TO QUOTES
FROM SEVERAL TOP DEMOCRATS WHO
ONCE SETTLEMENT AID BORDER WALL,
DID IT ABOUT A TWIST.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ON HIS
PUSH FOR THE WALL?
>> I'M NOT A FAN.
>> EVERYONE HAS A SHARED
REACTION TO THIS.
>> I REALLY DON'T SEE A NEED FOR
T. WE SHOULD SPEND MONEY TO
BUILD A BARRIER, TO PREVENT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT FROM COMING
IN.
WE CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO POUR
INTO THE U.S. UNTIL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE CONVINCED, WE WILL
STOP ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WE'LL MAKE NO PROGRESS.
WHEN YOU HEAR QUOTES LIKE THAT.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
>> DIVISIVE, I THINK AMERICA SAY
LAND OF OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK IT'S REALLY KIND OF
HATEFUL SPEECH IN GENERAL.
IT'S BEEN NEGATIVE.
>> WHAT IF I TOLD YOU THIS WAS
FROM CHUCK SCHUMER, BARACK OBAMA
AND HILARY CLINTON.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT.
>> RAIL?
OH, WOW.
TRUMP SAYS IT'S BAD.
NOW TRUMP'S PRESIDENT AND THE
WALL IS SUDDENLY IMMORAL.
ACTUALLY, DEMOCRATS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS PLAYING POLITICS AND
RISKING IN THE PROCESS, THE
LIVES OF AMERICAN CITIZENS, JUST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE DONALD
TRUMP.
WHO WANTS TO SOLVE A PROBLEM AND
YET, THE SOLUTION THEY ONCE
SUPPORTED IS EFFECTIVE.
WE KNOW THE LAW WORKS.
AFTER COMPLETION OF THE WALL,
SOUTH OF SAN DIEGO, ILLEGAL
TRAFFIC DROPS BY 92%.
THE WALL IN EL PASS OH, TEXAS,
RUMMED IN A SIGNIFICANT DROP AS
IT DID, WALLS  IN TUCSON AND
YUMA, ARIZONA, WHERE THEY
EXTENDED ONE WALL FROM FIVE
MILES  TO 65 MILES, IT DROPS 95%
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW REQUESTING
ONE TENNING OF 1 PERCENT OF OUR
FEDERAL BUDGET TO BUILD MORE
STRATEGIC BARRIERS AND IS
INCREASING INCREASED BORDER
PATROL, AND AN INCREASE IN
DETENTION CAPACITY AND
HUMANITARIAN RESOURCES AND
COUNTER SMUGGLING TOOLS ALONG
WITH OTHER PERSONALITY 10
NOOLOGY.
NOT A RADICAL PLAN.
A PLAN TO KEEP AMERICA SAFE.
IT ADDRESS WHAT IS IS AN URGENT
SERIOUS CRISIS.
SO LET ME SAY, I UNDERSTAND THE
OCCURRENCE.
25% PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
ARE FURLOUGHED.
WORKS FURLOUGHED.
I'VE BEEN THERE IN MY LIFE,
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
IT'S NOT FUN.
THEY WILL AND SHOULD AND DESERVE
TO RE COUPE ALL OF THEIR MONEY.
WHILE THEY'RE NOT WORKING, THEY
DESERVE T. THIS IS FOR OTHERS.
LIFE AND DEATH, LITERALLY,
PREVENTIBLE DEATH, WHICH MAKES
THIS ALL THE MORE FRUSTRATING
OFFICER SINGH IS GONE FOR THE.
THE COCHRANS WILL NEVER SEE
THEIR SONG PIERCE AGAIN.
THE FAMILIES OF THE PEOPLE YOU
SEE ON THE RIGHT OF YOUR SCREEN
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT TONIGHT,
THEY DESERVE BETTER.
THESE DEATHS ARE NOT
MANUFACTUREDS  IN NOT A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, AND
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES IN
THE MEDIA, THEIR TALKING POINT,
FRANKLY IS COLD, HEARTLESS, IT'S
A LIE AND FRANKLY, A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO EVERY ANGEL MOM AND DAD
AND FAMILY MEMBER IN THIS
COUNTRY, THAT HAVE LOST LOVED
ONCE, AS A RESULT OF OPEN
BORDERS OR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
OR EVERY FAMILY THAT HAS LOST A
LOVED ONE FROM A HEROIN OVER
DOSE THE CRASHES WITH BORDER
PATROL AGENTS, ROCKS, BOTTLES
THROWN, CHAOS, DESTRUCTION.
THAT'S NOT MANUFACTURED, THAT'S
REAL.
DEMOCRATS, REMEMBER, IT WASN'T A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS BECAUSE THEY
WERE POLITICALLY BLUDGEONING
TRUMP OVER THE FAMILY SEPARATION
ISSUE, SOMETHING HE EVENTUALLY
STOPPED THAT, HAPPENED IN THE
PREVIOUS TWO ADMINISTRATIONS.
WASN'T A MANUFACTURED CRISIS FOR
THE DEMOCRATS OR MEDIA WHEN THEY
WERE BLUDGEONING OUR BORDER
PATROL OFFICERS WHO HAD TO USE
TEAR GAS, BECAUSE THEY WERE
BEING PELTED  WITH ROCKS  AND
BOTTLES.
PELOSI, SCHUMER, THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THE MEDIA,
WANT TO STAY ON MANUFACTURED
CRISIS AND WANT THIS TO CONTINUE
AND PLAY A POLITICAL GAME.
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE THE FULL
AUTHORITY AND POWER TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND TACKLE
THIS HEAD OWITH OR WITHOUT
CONGRESSIONAL FUNDING APPROVAL
OR USE THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
HOMELAND LOOK AT THE NUMBER ON
YOUR SCREEN, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CALL, ASK YOUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS OR THE SENATE, TO HOLE